مع تصعيد التوترات بين موسكو من جهه
والغرب من جهه اخرى تضل نقطه تحول
الرئيسيه في مائده قرر الطرفان الدخول في
صراع مباشر لكن هل موسكو تفكر في الامر
ربما ذكره رئيس الوزراء البريطاني السابق
برج جونسون قد يشير الى ذلك العام الماضي
وجد جنس نفسه ضحيه تهديد مزعوم من الرئيس
الروسي بلادي ماركوتن ففي مكالمه هاتفيه
استثنائيه
ونبره صوت هادئه اخبر الرئيس الروسي
جونسون انه لا يريد ان يؤذيه لكنه تابع ان
ضربه صاروخيه بامكانها ان تسقطه وفي غضون
دقائق كانت هذه الكلمات بوتن منذ عام
والتي ظلت تطارد جنسن وبدا انه لم يتمكن
من نسيانها وفي حديث له مع هيئه الاذاعه
البريطانيه ضمن وثائقي جديد قال جونسن ان
تعليقات بوتن التي وصفها بالدنيا جاءت بعد
تهديده بفرض عقوبات اشد موسكو نتيجه حرب
اوكرانيا يكشف الوثائقي بعنوان بوتن ضد
الغرب عن لحظه اخرى مثيره للاهتمام
استذكرها وزير الدفاع البرتغنيه بن ويلز
الذي قال ان نظيره الروسيسور جيشيكو اخبره
خلال زيارته لموسكو ان الشعب الاوكراني لن
يرد في حاله تعرضه لهجوم روسيا
لا اريد ان اذيك لكن بصاروخ سيستغرق الامر
دقيقه واحده فقط او شيئا من هذا القبيل
ومع محاولتي لحمله على التفاوض قال بوريس
انت تقول ان اوكرانيا لن تنضم الى النيته
في اي وقت قريب ثم قال ما هو الوقت القريب
الذي تقصده وقلت حسنا لن تنضم الى النيه
حتى في المستقبل وانت تعلم ذلك جيدا